Roy Price et son équipe les surveillent
et enregistrent tout.
Ils enregistrent quand quelqu'un appuie sur lecture ou sur pause,
les parties sautées, les parties re-regardées.
Ils rassemblent des millions de données,
car ils veulent avoir ces données
pour ensuite décider quelle série sera réalisée.
Donc ils rassemblent ces données,
ils traitent ces données, et une réponse en est déduite,
la réponse est :
« Amazon devrait réaliser un sitcom
sur quatre sénateurs républicains américains. »
(Rires)
Et elle a été réalisée.
Quelqu'un connaît le nom de cette série ?
(Public) : « Alpha House. »
Exactement, « Alpha House »,
mais on dirait que presque personne ne se souvient de cette série
car elle n'a pas eu un très grand succès.
En réalité, c'est une série moyenne,
littéralement en fait, car 7,4 représente la moyenne de la courbe
et « Alpha House » tombe sur 7,5,
elle est juste au-dessus de la moyenne,
mais ce n'est certainement pas Roy Price et son équipe espéraient.
Cependant, au même moment,
dans une autre entreprise,
un autre cadre a trouver une bonne série grâce à l'analyse des données,
et il s'appelle Ted,
Ted Sarandos, directeur de l'acquisition des programmes de Netflix.
Et comme Roy, il est toujours à la recherche
d'une excellente série,
et il utilise aussi des données,
sauf qu'il s'y prend un peu différemment.
Au lieu d'organiser une compétition, lui et son équipe
ont pris les données qu'ils avaient déjà sur les utilisateurs de Netflix,
comme les notes attribuées aux séries,
leur historique, leurs séries préférées et tout ça.
Puis ils utilisent ces données pour découvrir
pleins de petites infos sur le public :
le genre de séries, de producteurs, d'acteurs ils apprécient.
Et au moment où ils ont tous les éléments nécessaires,
ils ont accompli un acte de foi
et ont décidé de créer
non pas un sitcom sur quatre sénateurs
mais une série dramatique sur un seul sénateur.
Vous connaissez cette série ?
(Rires)
Oui ! « House of Cards » et, bien sûr, Netflix a eu un grand succès,
au moins pour les deux premières saisons.
(Rires) (Applaudissements)
« House of Cards » a obtenu une note de 9,1 sur cette courbe,
donc, exactement ce qu'ils voulaient.
Évidemment, la question est : que s'est-il passé ?
On a deux entreprises concurrentes maîtrisant les données.
Elles lient ces millions de points de données
et ça marche superbement pour une,
mais pas pour l'autre.
Alors, pourquoi ?
La logique nous dit que ça devrait marcher à tous les coups.
Si vous rassemblez des millions de données
sur une décision à prendre,
vous devriez être capable de prendre la bonne décision.
On peut se fier à plus de 200 ans de statistiques.
On l'amplifie à l'aide des meilleurs ordinateurs.
La moindre des choses à laquelle on s'attend, c'est une bonne série, non ?
Et si l'analyse des données ne fonctionne pas comme ça,
on peut commencer à s'inquiéter,
parce que nous vivons à une époque où on utilise de plus en plus ces données
pour prendre des décisions sérieuses en dehors du monde de la télévision.
Est-ce-que quelqu'un ici connaît l'entreprise Multi-Health Systems ?
Personne, tant mieux.
Multi-Health Systems est une entreprise de logiciels,
et j'espère que personne du public n'aura à utiliser ce logiciel,
car si c'est le cas, vous êtes en prison.
(Rires)
Si un prisonnier des États-Unis demande une libération conditionnelle,
il est très probable que le logiciel d'analyse de données de cette compagnie
sera utilisé pour savoir s'il devrait l'obtenir.
C'est le même principe qu'Amazon et Netflix,
sauf que au lieu de voir si une série télé devrait sortir,
on décide si la personne devrait sortir.
Si une série télé médiocre de 22 minutes peut être mauvaise,
je suppose que passer plus longtemps en prison est pire.
Et malheureusement, il existe des preuves que cette analyse de données,
malgré leur abondance, ne donne pas toujours des résultats optimaux.
Mais, ce n'est pas parce que Multi-Health Systems
ignore que faire de ces données.
Même en maîtrisant les données, on peut se tromper.
Oui, parfois même Google se trompe.
En 2009, Google a annoncé qu'ils étaient capables,
à l'aide de l'analyse des données,
de prédire les épidémies d'influenza, la mauvaise grippe,
en analysant les données des recherches sur leur site.
Ça a bien marché, et ça a fait le buzz aux infos
y compris l'apogée des réussites scientifiques :
un article dans le journal « Nature ».
Ça marchait à tous les coups, année après année,
jusqu'à l'année où ça a échoué.
Et personne ne savait pourquoi.
Cette année-là, ça n'a pas marché
et, bien sûr, ça a refait le buzz,
y compris la rétraction
de la publication dans le journal « Nature ».
Même les entreprises maîtrisant ces données,
comme Amazon et Google,
font parfois des erreurs.
Et malgré tous ces échecs,
les données arrivent de plus en plus dans nos décisions de tous les jours :
dans le monde professionnel,
le monde du droit,
le monde de la médécine.
Donc, il faut nous assurer que ces données nous aident.
Moi-même, j'ai beaucoup vu ce problème avec les données
car je travaille dans l'informatique génomique,
un secteur rempli de personnes très intelligentes
qui utilisent un grand nombre de données
pour prendre des décisions sérieuses
comme choisir un traitement pour cancer, développer un médicament.
Au cours des années, j'ai remarqué un modèle,
ou même une règle, sur la différence
entre des bonnes décisions à l'aide des données
et des mauvaises décisions,
et je trouve que ce modèle vaut la peine d'être partagé,
ça se présente comme ceci.
Quand il faut résoudre un problème compliqué,
il y a deux étapes essentielles.
Un : il faut diviser le problème en plusieurs parties
pour pouvoir les analyser de manière profonde,
et puis deux : bien sûr,
il s'agit de remettre ces pièces ensemble
pour conclure.
Et parfois il faut réessayer,
mais c'est toujours ces deux choses :
déconstruire le problème et le remonter.
Et la partie clé
est que l'analyse de ces données
n'est valable que pour la première partie.
Les données et l'analyse, peu importe leur puissance,
n'aideront qu'à déconstruire le problème
pour comprendre les éléments qui le composent.
Ça n'aidera pas à remettre les pièces ensemble
pour en arriver à une conclusion.
Il existe un outil qui fait ça, que nous possédons tous :
le cerveau.
Si notre cerveau est bon pour une chose,
c'est assembler divers éléments ensemble,
même avec des pièces manquantes,
et arriver à une bonne conclusion,
surtout si c'est le cerveau d'un expert.
Et c'est grâce à ça que Netflix a eu un tel succès :
ils ont utilisé les données et les cerveaux au moment où il fallait.
Ils ont d'abord utilisé les données pour comprendre leur public,
ce qu'ils n'auraient pas été capables de comprendre sans ça,
mais la décision de prendre toutes ces informations
et les remettre ensemble pour créer une série comme « House of Cards »,
n'était pas dans les données.
Ted Sarandos et son équipe ont décidé d'autoriser la création de cette série,
ce qui voulait aussi dire qu'ils prenaient
un grand risque personnel avec cette décision.
À l'inverse, Amazon a fait cela dans le mauvais ordre.
Ils ont utilisé beaucoup de données pour faire leur choix,
en organisant une compétition d'idées de séries,
puis en choisissant de produire « Alpha House ».
C'était bien sûr prudent comme décision de leur part,
car ils pouvaient accuser les donnés et dire :
« C'est ce que disaient les données. »
Mais ça ne leur a pas donné les résultats exceptionnels qu'ils espéraient.
Les données sont extrêmement utiles pour prendre de meilleures décisions
mais je pense qu'il y a un problème
quand les données nous mènent à ces décisions.
Peu importe leur puissance, les données ne sont qu'un outil,
et pour toujours garder ça en tête, j'ai trouvé un outil très utile.
La plupart d'entre vous...
(Rires)
Avant les données,
on utilisait cet outil pour prendre des décisions.
(Rires)
Vous le connaissez,
ce jouet s'appelle la Magic 8 Ball
et il est génial,
car si vous avez un choix à faire, une question fermée,
il suffit de secouer la boule pour obtenir une réponse --
« Très Probable » -- juste ici, une réponse en temps réel.
J'en ferai la démonstration plus tard.
(Rires)
Le truc c'est que, évidemment -- j'ai pris des décisions dans la vie
où, en rétrospective, j'aurais dû écouter la boule.
Mais, évidemment, si les données sont disponibles,
on veut remplacer ça avec quelque chose de plus sophistiqué,
comme l'analyse des données, pour en arriver à une meilleure décision.
Mais cela ne change pas le concept de base.
La boule peut devenir de plus en plus intelligente,
mais je pense que c'est toujours à nous de décider
si on veut faire quelque chose d'extraordinaire,
du côté droit de la courbe.
Et je trouve ça très encourageant comme message en fait,
que même quand on a toutes ces données devant nous,
ça nous rapporte quelque chose de prendre ces décisions,
d'être expert dans notre domaine
et de prendre des risques.
Car à la fin, ce ne sont pas les données,
ce sont les risques qui vous amènent du côté droit de la courbe.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)